so in this session we are going to talk
about scaling your micro services with
grpc containers kubernetes
Etc right
so we'll start talking about what's jrpc
and like
why grpc should be something that you
should consider in order to build
microservices because microservices you
guys know is kind of like the new
buzzword in the tech right we are kind
of very much indulged into the phase
where everything that we want to build
is kind of somewhere somewhat related to
microservices we are gone are the days
for the monolith although ah I still
like recently worked somewhere where a
lot of monolith code was there but okay
we'll be talking about those things
we'll be talking uh how exactly
kubernetes come into the picture a lot
of things we are going to discuss so
without any further delay let's just
start
so who am I why I'm here I am sanket
Singh I'm a software engineer at Google
uh at Google I work with Google pay I'm
not sure how many of you guys have used
it but I work with the client team for
Google pay previously worked with Google
Cloud as well
uh I previously worked with LinkedIn
again as a software engineer in the
Enterprise provisioning team
uh apart from
the regular software engineering work
that we get and the jira tickets we have
to solve I spent some time in also
training and teaching students online
around foundations of computer science
dbms data structures a bit of Dev Etc
kind of like a big uh superhero fan a
bit of Marvel and DC stuff is going to
be there in the presentation so just to
make things a bit light-hearted right so
if you get the references give a thumbs
up
Okay so
what to expect from the session right
what and why about grpc why it actually
came into the picture why we are talking
about why we are talking now about
things around RPC
comparisons and comparisons with other
conventions so comparison with the rest
and everything
right will be also talking about
how you can set up a basic grpc server
and client in Python right although it
supports multiple languages but we can
see a bit of python and how exactly
containers in kubernetes come into the
picture and how exactly you you can use
this in order to scale your micro
services
okay
so
before we move forward to grpc lets ah
get based on the favorite that we have
rest right so ah rest is more or less
like a convention for us it defines a
lot of things a lot of applications that
you guys might have already built or
might be building or maybe you have used
may have exposed some of some of the
rest API endpoints right so rest is
something that we already use it's
widely accepted widely used I I believe
that most of the organizations uh
nowadays definitely have some part
somewhere dedicated towards which is
using rest and in the micro Services
world we use these apis in order to
communicate right the rest apis in order
to communicate
it's kind of flexible it doesn't put a
lot of restriction
for you as a developer right it's easy
to use like writing a basic rest API in
something like node or python is going
to be a five minute thing for us right
even less than that sometimes so it's
easy to use it's kind of like widely
accepted right it's compatible with
browsers like whatever browsers we are
using currently nowadays it's compatible
with it right
a lot of things also comes along with
the rest conventions like we have
predefined set of codes the status codes
that we have defined in order to see
what is the current status of the I
would say service that we are having
right the API that we are that we have
written along with that there are
dedicated Frameworks I'm not sure how
many of you guys have used it but
definitely you must have heard about it
like Django rails which are like
dedicated dedicatedly walking around
rest right most of the scaffoldings and
everything work with rest and they are
like power packed with all the support
rest from our uh out of the box so rest
is something that is already there like
it was already there for quite some time
and here comes grpc so
you must have already heard about RPC
remote procedure calls right
so it's an open source system developed
by Google
grpc is an open source system developed
by Google in 2015. now if you think the
G in the grpc is Google that's not the
case it's nowhere written but we'll
assume
Maybe
ok
so Google doesn't tell everything right
so they are not even telling the full
form but
it was developed by Google in 2015 so
quite recent
it uses HTTP 2.0 one of the most
important features that grpc comes out
of the box that definitely enhances the
overall I would say performance of your
apis
it uses something called as Proto call
buffers we also call them as protobuf
Proto Proto buffers whatever you want to
say it is again one of the most
highlighted features that grpc provides
we are going to talk about protocol
buffers we will try to write one as well
apart from that grpc is fast it's secure
it contains features like automatic load
balancing and much more right so it has
a lot lot of things to offer right and
it makes sense for us like we are in
2022 and it makes sense for us to
understand that okay apart from rest
again comparing rest directly to
something like grpc won't be a very
valid comparison
rest is just a convention right but when
I say rest then I mean your regular Json
apis when you consume Json you return
Json everything that we are actually I
would say referring when I compare rest
with grpc because grpc is not just
convention it's a full end-to-end
technology that you can use in order to
write services and again it's going to
be super fast
but why now like we are kinda kinda
comfortable with rest right we have
Frameworks we are consuming the apis
things are going fine right there is
already a straight way in which we can
build our applications why do we want to
add something spicy to it let's see
so
if something is already going good does
not make doesn't mean that it is not
having any kind of problems
to be very honest saying that there are
some problems with rest is kind of like
an opinionated thing I am saying
problems with rest it's kind of like an
opinion right you might not find these
as a problem right but let's see few of
the things that we have
so in Json in the earlier days we had
this type checking issues right for API
changes you have to do semantic
versioning like you must have either
encountered an API or you must have made
an API with that slash V1 slash V2
everything like you have to specifically
version your apis every time
streaming is something that doesn't come
out of the box
for rest right you cannot do
bi-directional streaming kind of a thing
there are other solution like web
sockets and everything but it doesn't
come out of the box
by default it supports HTTP 1.1 I know
that a lot of networking thing we are
like discussing I can't help I used to
work in the network networking team only
earlier at Google so just bear with me
we'll be coming to the coding part but
uh talking about rests HTTP support it
by default supports HTTP 1.1 you can
migrate to the latest version but it by
default give you this functionality only
you can of of course migrate it you have
to do manual validations and one of the
most important I would say pointer that
exists there with rest is the management
of the client-side libraries
if you are consuming a rest API
with python there is a separate
library that is maintained by a separate
organization if by Ruby separate if by
node.js separate like whatever language
or framework you are using there is a
separate dedicated team or separate
dedicated Community separate dedicated
set of developers who are creating this
client-side apis for these Technologies
right now just think about it
if in rest in the later upcoming days we
make some changes then you can't expect
every client-side library to get
migrated in single day right
this is again one of the I would say
problems that you may think that okay we
will deal with it when the time comes
but again this can be an issue
and we have grpc to the rescue
right these problems specifically grpc
is definitely able to handle because by
default
grpc gives the support of HTT HTTP 2.0
we are not going to talk very much in
depth around how HTTP 2.0 is like faster
than the previous version but in a
nutshell you can understand it gives us
new features like Multiplex and
multiplexing and everything so
it definitely
increases your efficiency
instead of Json instead of Json like in
the rest apis or let's say if we go even
even back like before the days of rest
soap simple object access protocol I'm
not sure how many of you guys have even
heard about it then we used to share XML
I believe everybody must have at least
seen some example I know it's like old
age stuff XML and like soap I I'm not
sure if you have heard about it but yes
these things do exist and
the thing is we will be comparing XML
and Json with our protocol buffers but
as per the convention says and to be
very honest grpc puts this as a
restriction that you have to use
protocol buffers and we'll see there are
definitely some benefits of protocol
buffers
over Json and XML
because of protocol buffers
the API contract that we are going to
build is going to be strict right and
this functionality comes out of the box
you don't have to put anything extra any
other framework any other service to do
it this strict API contract is going to
help us to do all the validation kind of
stuff
there are built-in code generators I
will talk about what what I mean by
being built-in code generators but you
can say that the problem of different
client-side libraries for different
languages and Frameworks is something
that grpc solves we will talk about it
it has services like in build load
balancing
and apart from that
for the streaming part you can do
bi-directional streaming as well
directly server to client streaming as
well client to server streaming as well
and your basic unary requests as well
and
it is more secure
and of course we are
going to talk about the fact that it's
faster than rest right
it's definitely faster
so
if you if ah like there is no if if you
will see a lot of I have linked a few
stack Overflow links in my presentation
that you can find in the speaker notes I
don't write speaker notes I instead put
some reference links but uh you will
find that in the normal production you
will find seven to eight percent I would
say efficiency increase with grpc and
that is going to be significantly big if
you talk with if you talk on scale right
if you talk with the things like the
scale at which Google or let's say any
social media works these things are
going to be important
so
how is it faster
so there is a concept of serialization
and deserialization of data into binary
format that protocol buffer use I'll be
showing an example in front of you in
just a moment but the thing is protocol
buffer serializes your data like you are
going to send a message right in Json we
always used to send our J like let's say
an ID text this and that in a complete
Json and send it to the API either to
consume or receive it from the API right
and so we do the same thing using XML
right so
in protocol buffers it does not directly
send your protocol buffer
in the communication medium it first
serializes that data into binary format
and our favorite binary can definitely
reduce
the whole overall size to a very extreme
limit
we have already talked about the fact
that it uses HTTP 2.0 it can support
multiple type of streaming and things
like inbuilt load balancing
so
this is an example right so I have taken
this example from one of the medium
articles again Linked In the speaker
notes right so for a string medium
right if you just want to send a string
medium and we have three ways to send it
you can send it via Json you can send it
via XML you can send it with the
protocol buffers
if you send it by a Json this is how the
overall format if this is how the
overall information that will be sent
looks like
the above one is XML
it's big right its definitely definitely
big and
you can see with protocol buffers that
it serializes your data into the binary
format
and it is quite small and this is just
for one basic small string like medium
if you have a very big chunk of messages
on that you want to send or receive this
is going to be really helpful
right
so according to the official
documentation that Google releases
protocol buffers are Google's language
neutral so first of all this is language
neutral no matter what technology you
are using this is going to work
platform neutral
extensible mechanism for serializing
structure data
think XML
but smaller
faster and simpler
right you can Define
how you want your data to be structured
once and then you can use special
generated source code easily write and
read your structured data to form a
variety of data streams using a variety
of languages right so Google officially
mentions it that Google is going to
handle the generation of the code for
all of the languages we will see an
example with python as well
so Google took it upon itself right as I
said there is a problem right the
problem of the client-side libraries
that there are different communities who
are maintaining the client-side
libraries but that's not the case with
grpc for with grpc if you are using grpc
with your microservices
then
whatever changes are going to be there
it is going to be shipped
managed maintained just by Google most
of the languages that we at least in
2022 use Java node c-sharp go Ruby
Python and there are separate other
languages also for which Googles
releases the support
the thing is all you have to do is just
prepare your protocol buffers
and the automatic code generator the
compilers that Google releases you have
to just use that and it will generate
the code for you that you can directly
consume you don't have like all of this
code generation part is abstracted you
don't have to care about it you just
have to care about the logic that you
want to write with your service and
that's it you don't need to care about
the fact that whether the client Side
Library is currently supporting some
feature or not everything is going to be
handled at one point of time by Google
so this is something that I would say
the whole load Google took it upon
themselves
so we can see a small example right and
let's see uh like how this overall code
generation thing works right
okay so how much time we have okay
so
let's do one thing
I guess this screen is not working
okay just a second
okay
so this is like a basic python I would
say
project I'm not sure it's like hardly
having 100 lines of code even less but
it's a small python service that I have
created and what do we do uh
yeah sure
Okay cool so it's a small python service
that I have built right and first of all
before we do anything else let us talk
about the Proto this is the protocol
buffer right
so this is the overall syntax that you
have to use in order to prepare a
protocol buffer it's going to be a
strict contract it's going to be a
straight contract that you have to use
right for example we are going to define
a message object that is going to be
called as to do item this is going to
have two parameters an ID that is going
to be an integer and a text that is
going to be a string now this is
something that is going to be now strict
from here you cannot pass anything else
in your text or ID like any other data
you can but but we can do that with Json
right we can have a key and whatever
value we put we can do that but that's
not the case which uh with protocol
buffers right if you want to have
something which is optional that's your
that you are not going to send every
time for example
like in rest we have this syntax where
if you are going to do something like
slash API slash V1 slash to do and it's
a get request you get all the to-do's
but if you do slash API slash V1 slash
to do slash one
and it's a get request you get the first
to do right so you can define a message
object like to do item which is having
ah which is uh to do request which is
going to have an optional ID if you want
to send an ID you can send it otherwise
it is going to be optional so this kind
of a syntax is going to work if you want
to send an array of items you have to
specifically mention that it is going to
be like for here for array you have to
mention it as repeated and things are
going to work like that
and
here you define your RPC
now in grpc again as I said grpc apart
from being a technology gives you a set
of conventions as well just like rest
right in rest the major form of
information is what your resource for
example to do is a resource you create
your apis you create the URLs for the
apis based on the resource
what grpc recommends grpc says that you
should you should build this urls based
on action like when you have to create
to do just say slash create to do when
you have to do read to do just say slash
read to do right so you have to be yeah
like you have to Define your action
instead of resource right and this is
how you define just your RPC
RPC create to do read to do it is going
to take a to-do item create to do is
going to create a like receiver to do
item and return a to-do item as well
for re to do you are going to receive a
to-do request that is of course having
an optional ID that we already discussed
about and it is going to return to do
items that it can return one item like
it is just a dummy I would say Proto
buffer okay
now
as I said this is the basic protocol
buffer that we have right
now
Google release Google released this
compiler for different I would say
language even for python there is a
dedicated one so you can just use the
grpc tools dot protoc in order to
generate
some code as I said that is going to act
as your client-side code right so
if I show you the exact code what it
generates so here you can see there are
two files to do underscore pb2 dot grpc
one is this one and ah sorry and this
one right so these are the two set of
files that this automatic I would say
compiler kind of a thing is going to do
so
if you read this file if you want to
read this file
you will see that it is going to define
something called as a stub it is going
to do everything on its own it's going
to Define
your URL for slash create to do it is
going to set everything like set all the
codes and detail whatever it has to do
it is going to do everything on its own
like all of this code is going to get
generated you don't have to care what is
getting generated you just have to use
it right everything is going to be
managed by Google
if there is any change if there is any
Nuance that is going to get changed it
will automatically get shipped right
and then
and the most important part these kind
of compilers is available in all of the
languages that supports grpc right okay
then all you have to do is just start
setting up a server right
so we are going to like start writing
the request I can show the exact code as
well but you can we can go here by step
by step so we'll be defining two
functions create to do read to do right
right apart from that we are going to
set up the survey in order to set up the
server all you have to do is just make a
just mention that what port you have to
use right ah later we are going to
containerize it as well right and you
all you have to do is
add to do servicer to server right like
this function is already getting
generated from the client-side code that
we got all you have to do is just create
the object of the to-do service that we
just created here this to do service we
created all we have to do just pass the
object and the server context that we
have to pass and we can start the server
right
for the implementation all you have to
do
is again consume the same
protocol buffer messages right so here
you can see that we are creating
ah for create to do we are creating a to
do item for this to to do item we are
setting an ID setting a text and then we
are
just uh returning that reply I have
already maintained I am also maintaining
a to-do's to-do's array just to ensure
some kind of a I would say persistence
and same thing in read to Do's that you
have to just create this to do items now
the thing is if we are not going to
follow the data types that we have
mentioned if we are going to send
anything else
ins instead of the integer or the string
that we have defined it's going star it
will start throwing error so it is going
to be strict the contract is going to be
strict okay
apart from that you can also set up your
client
so in order to set up the client all you
have to do is set up a Channel with the
corresponding servers Post Port
you have to create a stub and you can
just start making the call so here you
can see we are making the call of create
to do and create to do expects a to-do
item as well so we are going to create a
to do item object here with id1 let us
say text is equals to new to do and we
are going to just make a call and that's
it right if you have to read to Do's you
can just again make a request object
with the expectation and you can just
make the call so
I would say
in the first impression this might look
like a lot of work to do you have to
prepare a protocol buffer you have to
use the compiler to create all of the
code right then you can start writing
your server and the client
yes of course
in very small scale application like if
you definitely have to make a to-do app
this is too much right this is going to
be very beneficial when you have large
scale application when you have a very
big application where a lot of apis you
have written there are a lot of micro
services that you have in those kind of
cases these kind of implementations
where you have strict contract is going
to help you a lot
so again you can just run your python
server and from the client you can start
making the calls and it will just
directly connect we can definitely see
our demonstration as well
but
as I said for the pros and cons if you
will see grpc is going to be if if you
are just if you have just started right
your first like you are creating your
first to do application then something
like something like grpc can be a bit
overwhelming
rest is simple I will definitely agree
to the fact and you guys might agree to
the same thing as well that rest is
quite simple right it's not as
complicated and there are not a lot of
steps to get onboarded it literally
takes less than five minutes to create a
rest API with python but with grpc you
have to do some steps but if you have a
lot of micro services that are
interacting right and then later just
think about it in the later stages if
the contracts of one micro service
changes
then in the other micro Services also it
will be a strict implementation to do
right so there are benefits there are
pros and cons both for grpc as well and
for rest again it depends on what
business use case we have it depends on
what are our requirements what is the
scale that we are working on based on
that we have to
make a choice
but
this was about grpc like
in this talk I added two components one
was grpc that is going to help you make
your services faster the interaction the
efficiency is going to be increased
right apart from that apart from that
our favorite containers right I'm not
sure how many of you guys have used it
but definitely you must have heard about
docker right the containers like there
are other Technologies available as well
but
using containerization
we can definitely scale up and
improve our micro Services even further
and that
leads us to something called as
kubernetes
so again kubernetes
is something released by Google so
earlier and still till till this date we
use something called as Borg right
Borges
and internal Google tech
and you can say that kubernetes is just
a sophisticated cleaner open source
version of Borg right
what kubernetes is kubernetes
is container orchestrator if like if I
have to Define kubernetes in two words
its container orchestrator the same
thing Borg is still doing right and we
we are heavily dependent on bark but we
cannot just release Borg make it open
source right
everybody can use it no so there are
some changes ah that were done and that
led to the
technology kubernetes right
I would say that kubernetes is one of
the I would say most important things if
you are working on scale ah that exist
out there in the developer Community
kubernetes is also called as k8s like
just remove the K just remove the S
there are eight characters in between we
are lazy we replace the eight characters
with eight and it creates so a lot of
time you will find people
saying it as K eights but
kubernetes has got a lot of I would say
use cases being a container orchestrator
kubernetes can do a lot of things on the
go very easily
first of all
like there are some terminologies that
we can talk about so there is a there is
something called as pod right so the
smallest unit that you can build is a
pod right and it works on the
I'm not sure like what's the better
version to say it but there's like a
master node and there are like worker
nodes let us not ah let us call it as
worker nodes so what kubernetes does is
it manages everything on the go if one
of the worker if one of the worker nodes
goes down it will automatically turn up
one more right on the go if you want
that you uh if you if you feel the need
that you want to have more workers you
can scale or deployment by just one
Command right and kubernetes has got a
very significant I would say support for
most of the platforms right be it if you
are developing your server on Linux Mac
or Windows right
and definitely the documentations is
really very good
so
let us talk about it
so what I have done here is like in the
actual implementation here also if you
will see I have changed the client code
to a basic flask kind of an application
if you will see client dot py I've like
commented out all of this and I have
created this basic flask API where I can
have one slash create to do and slash
read to do it is again consuming all of
the grpc code in the same manner right
then all you have to do is containerize
your server and the client for
containerization we can use Docker right
so this is a basic I would say Docker
file that we have to create we have to
just mention the environment right
inside in the inside the container we
have to just copy our requirements.txt
that is going to have all the libraries
that we have will be copying the server
and we'll be installing all the required
dependencies and we will be again using
the same I would say code generator in
order to create the stubs and things
will be done
apart from that you have to create a
Docker file again similar like to server
you have to create it for the client
right as the client is a flask cap so
you need to have these environment
variables uh set and running
then what you can do is you can
build your container and then you can
run it we'll talk about like why exactly
containers come into the picture but you
can just set up your Docker container
like this you will find this network
micro Services flag that I have
mentioned so in order to in order like
first of all we are setting up our
containers then we are going to push
this container to kubernetes so in order
for two containers to interact it's a
good way that we set up a networking
mechanism so Docker also ships with that
so we have set up a micro services like
I've just named the channel to be
microservices and then the same thing we
have to do for the client as well is
just that the ports will be different
one port is like separate for a port for
client and separate for Server apart
from that in the client code if you will
see I'm using a host as grpc server uh
if you see here
right this is the host that we are using
so it is going to get that from the
environment variable for our Docker
instance and
things will be done this will
containerize the whole application now
the thing is why do we need to
containerize
back
again like
quite a few years back when Cloud
systems like gcp AWS all of the all of
these things were not exactly in place
bare metals that we say in technical
terms were there you have to manually
set up a machine
you have to manually turn up your
servers if you have to scale it up you
have to scale the like the ability of
your machine or you have to put separate
machines and then came these cloud
services came into the picture AWS gcp
that made things a bit more virtual
right you can just go and create a
virtual server and things are done
now how exactly containers fit into this
it provides you kind of like a protected
environment otherwise you don't know
that on one actual Cloud machine which
is there in their data center how many
actual servers are working
so maybe
two different I would say applications
are running on the same machine and they
are interacting with each other or maybe
you just uh log into one of the ec2
hosts and you are able to access someone
else file so that's why containerization
comes into the picture it's a bit uh it
makes the overall environment more
secure and in order to use kubernetes it
makes sense to use these containers
now for setting up kubernetes it's just
like
one single file that you have to create
a yaml file it's just a bit of
configurations that you have to do and
that's it right so in the configurations
only what you can do is you can mention
how many replicas of the pods you want
to have five seven ten and these are
going to be changeable on the go like
you are running already your server
right it's already having its five
instances running and you want to scale
up
it can be done right so
all you have to do
initially in order to set up your
kubernetes
in order to set up the kubernetes all
you have to do is just prepare a yaml
file in the yaml file set up the
containers for both client and the
server right so here you can see for the
grpc client as well as the server both
of them I have mentioned here I am not
pulling the image from Docker Hub or
let's say Google Cloud right I am
pulling the image directly from my local
that's why the image pull policy is
never right apart from that we have to
expose what ports these containers are
going to use inside kubernetes and
the previous yaml files that I showed
you these are for setting up your
deployment servers now in order to
access these deployment servers you have
to create Services again just few
configurations that you have to do right
you have to set up the service you have
to ex expose the ports right and here
you can see in the client this is for
the server the client is interacting the
server we are going to enter we will be
interacting with the client in the
client you can mention this type as
cluster IP node port or load balancer
and yes you heard it right
so if you are integrating kubernetes
with let us say AWS Google Cloud
platform digitalocean whatever like
available Cloud platforms are there
which supports kubernetes deployment you
can use directly their load balancers we
are not going to use it because again
depends on what service you are using it
may charge you but again if you have to
scale up things on the go having a load
balancer makes a lot of sense because it
will automatically route the request to
the least like let's say whatever policy
you are using based on that it is going
to Route the request to the
corresponding server
and that's it and that's it this is all
you have to do in order to set up a
kubernetes I would say application
now let's see ah
ok
so let us try to see that how when I
said that if you have a kubernetes I
would say instance running you can scale
up or scale down your deployments that
is going to be easy so because we are
doing this deployment on the local we
are not using any dedicated Cloud
platform that is going to give us the
IPS and everything you can use tools
like mini Cube mini cube is something
that you can use for both Linux as well
as Mac right and apart from that
uh there is a tool called as cube CTL
so
you can do something like Cube CTL
okay I am not able to exactly see but
Cube CTL apply minus F and let us say
the yaml file that you have written is
server.yaml
right
okay it says these are created
so it ah directly created a kubernetes
instance for us now what we can do is we
can go to the mini mini Cube dashboard
so mini cube is a tool you can directly
install it we are not going to see the
installation and everything we will just
see exactly how you can do it so let's
say if you do mini Cube dashboard
one second
okay it is going to fire up the
dashboard for us where we can see if the
services are up
so let me show you is going to be a
local dashboard if you are using any
Cloud platform then you can you will be
having their dedicated dashboards
okay
and let's see
let's
so let us go to deployments
okay now here you can see
because we mentioned that for each for
both like client and server we want five
replicas each so these five replicas are
working so if you will open you can
see all the logs and dedicated I would
say
action items for them now let us say
that you want to scale up right you want
to scale up your deployment to let's say
10 right
ah just a second yep so what you can say
is
Cube CTL
scale deployment and let us say for the
server instead of five replicas now we
want to have 10 all you have to do is
just pass a flag minus minus replica is
equals to ten
and it says the server scaled now if you
go here
you can see
from five dedicated instances now you
have ten
its that easy
right it is that easy to just scale up
at any point of time right so that's
where kubernetes come into the picture
that if you have a lot of micro services
and if you if at any point of time any
one of the service you want to scale up
scale down if you want to have very high
availability so a lot of times we have
dedicated Services which is expected to
have extremely high availability then
kubernetes is something that we can
directly use if any of the nodes goes
down it is going to turn up at the same
moment of time one more replica for it
right so kubernetes is going to help us
with that and if you like if let's say
if you want to test your kubernetes that
is like we are not we have not deployed
it on any Cloud platform if you want to
just test your kubernetes to in on your
local you can set up something called as
Ingress right that comes ah as a by
default support for kubernetes and you
will be able to make a call directly
through Ingress
so
At Last At Last I would like to say that
if we have if we have like ah when I was
working with LinkedIn the whole
architecture was exactly set up with
microservices so if you have a huge
bunch of microservices that are
interacting with each other then
you can use both grpc and kubernetes as
two separate fronts which will help you
to scale up your services using grpc not
only you get efficiency
not only you get better reliability and
security but you get
contracts which are going to be strict
with kubernetes and containerizations
all you have to do is just see what is
the expectation and whenever you want to
scale it up you can scale up your
services you can manage inter-service
Communications containerization
automatically is going to be there
because it's the requirement for setting
up kubernetes and what not so
on and on I would say grpc is something
definitely worth a try ah if you are
building something very small I at least
never use something like I would have
never used something like jrpc for
something very small but I would say
that if there is like very complex
communication that you have to do jrpc
makes a lot of sense
cool so I guess we have some time so ah
we can ah definitely take up some
questions if you have
Okay so
so as I said
apart like of course you can do the load
balancing part manually also like grpc
comes with its inbuilt capability for
load balancing so let me show you
so
foreign
side load balancing this is a very good
article from Microsoft
I'm not sure why
for understanding grpc we have a
Microsoft article but ah you can see
that for the client side load balancing
the client that you have set up ah grpc
comes with its inbuilt capability of
doing the load balancing right uh you
can have separate strategies like
whatever strategy you want to have for
the load balancing part you can do that
all the DNS resolution and everything is
going to be done right so if you go here
for the strategy part it defines two
strategies
the pick first and the round robin and
all you have to do is just configure
your load balancing there and whatever
servers you will be having it will
automatically reroute your requests
because you have dedicated you have set
up a dedicated channel in order to
connect the client to the server now
it's grpc it will which will be deciding
if let's say you set it up it will be
grpc which will be deciding what server
to hit so you can definitely use that
like I've already added this article in
the speaker notes so you can also read
about it
is there any
or something I guess
uh I'm not sure about the browser part
but yes there is some support that has
been released with the browser I myself
have never worked with grpc on browser
but initial in the initial days it was
definitely a hiccup with the browsers
but yes there exists some support so I
might have to look at it but I have not
first-handedly used uh grpc with browser
so yeah we have to check it up
okay
is there any best practices around
sharing portable buffers in those cigars
sharing protocol like again you can
Define your protocol buffer as a in a
similar manner that you define a
contract right and the client side as I
said the client-side library that Google
provides is going to automatically
generate the code for everyone let's say
you have three services that are
consuming sending the same protocol
buffer like either consuming or sending
now all you have to do is use the same
protocol buffer signature right a common
protocol buffer signature is going to
get used and whatever client side like
you can set it up separately and
whatever client-side Library you are
using let's say a ruby service node
service python service you can use the
Python's compiler and the Gen code
generator that to generate the same
protocol buffer code for python or node
service and same for Ruby service now if
you are using the same generated code
then it is automatically going to ensure
the fact that you are
handling the contract in the same manner
in all the three services so it's going
to be common there
yeah anyone
foreign
so I I'm assuming that whenever we do
any kind of debugging logging or
anything we do on the service end right
the the thing about sending a binary is
when you are going to send the message
then over the network
you are sending a binary so it's like a
small payload right
it does the serialization and
deserialization part on the end service
so when you are going to get the message
it will decide it's not like you are
sending the message it serializes it and
the other service is going to consume
the serialized must know it is going to
deserialize it so for the debugging and
logging part there won't be an issue
it's just that when you are sending the
message on the network the overall data
packet that you are sending is now small
right so the same amount of information
is getting sent with a smaller packet
that leads to a faster transmitting
transmission of the overall data so for
the debugging and logging purpose
because you do it on the end service
right you like we just don't go to the
network layer and then see okay where's
where's our packet that's the same thing
here we are just going to debug on the
end service and things should be fine
and like for debugging like whatever
technology you're using python Ruby
there are dedicated debugging tools we
can use
oh
what do we what do we I mean what are we
talking talking about about
the contract always
applications that exists on
talk about something else okay so let me
give an example so let's say that you
have we have a node service let's say we
have two services so uh one service is
exposing an API and one service is
consuming an API
so while consuming an API let us say
sorry while exposing an API let us say
the API expected you to send an integer
right for some let us say cost
when you are sending a request from the
other side
you didn't send
an integer you send a string so how you
are going to check you have to do manual
validation right that is not the case
with grpc
the moment the other service is going to
try is going to violate the protocol
buffer that's BS that will be a strict
that's a strict contract it's going to
throw an error on that on their end only
that hey I didn't expect a string please
send a text
that's the part you don't have to do
manual validation right like I still
remember writing my first express
application and dedicatedly writing
separate middlewares for validations but
that kind of hustle that kind of like
again that extra code that you we will
be writing is kinda getting saved here
right so I guess that answers the
question
so if your authenticated users only are
trying to access so how about you like
like what's the problem with a regular
authentication Service
like I'm not like
we just we just want an authenticated
user only to uh access our API right
that's
okay so first thing is uh securing on
the transport layer like the message
part because we are serializing and
deserializing the data the okay I'm not
sure if I mentioned that in the talk or
the question but the serialization and
deserialization of the data
happens on the end client it doesn't it
doesn't like any other Intruder cannot
just pass or like read the message in
between so you will be getting a binary
right you are not going to get our raw
data first thing uh offer secure
communication comes directly here so
that's first level of security apart
from that you can have manual like in
just the same manner like your rest
regular rest apis have their dedicated
uh validation and authentication you can
do the same setup here as well so like
the serialization part happens on the
end machine it's not like we can
intercept the CL like intercept the
communication in between will be getting
a binary we won't be able to see okay
what's inside that
uh
okay so like uh for dedicated yeah that
that makes sense that we have a better
token strategy that we can directly send
over the headers uh for grpc that like
dedicated headers doesn't exist but yes
you can use a separate I would say a
separate service you can definitely
create for your authentication and
authorization right I'm not sure about
any headers that we can send with grpc
we have to maybe look at it but yes like
a dedicated authentication Service you
can definitely build on the grpc
yep sure
for example
okay so uh
so let me understand the question so
from the client to the server if let's
say if at any point of time we are not
able to complete the communication right
we can have retry mechanisms there in
the same way that we have like if it
it's reaching our message key if it's
add the message queue then we can have
manual uh workarounds like the retry
part if let us say in the layer lets
because in the transport layer ah we
have this TCP like in the TCP protocol
we have this sense of I would say
security about the fact that a packet
that we are going to send it's going to
be like a reliable way of communication
right so for that part we are again
going to use the same transport layer
but for if let us say if we are able to
receive the message uh on our message
queue like it's a queue that's uh set we
have set up in between the two servers
we can have dedicated retry mechanism
setup in place
yeah sure sir like
okay so the same word like again first
uh sorry first of all uh like versioning
as I said issue might not be an issue
for everyone first thing second thing ah
using protocol buffers as I said uh
whenever we are going to change the
Proto buff all we have to do is just do
the Regeneration of the uh code using
the compilers it is going to handle
everything you don't have to set up a
separate like set of routes to expose
the I would say new set of contracts if
you have a new protocol buffer set up in
place all you have to do is just do the
recompilation of the code everything is
going to get generated for you that's
how we are going to avoid separate
dedicated versioning that we have to now
uh let me answer now let us say now you
consider a case when let us say one of
our service is not consuming the updated
protobuf right so there can be case that
let us say we updated the Proto buff
most of the services are consuming but
still there are a dedicated like still
there is a service that is not consuming
the updated protobufs in those kind of
cases we have to do some manual checks
right we have to make sure that our
previous Proto buff is getting supported
but you don't have to reroute everything
or like write new routes like for API
versioning that we do we have a separate
set of routes slash V1 then slash V2
then slash V3 we don't have to do that
all we can do is the same RPC the
previous RPC is also getting supported
by few of the servers that other
services that are still not migrated can
use and then later by with time we can
do that or you can have a stricter
implementation that no matter what if
this like the updated protobuf you are
not going to use we are not going to
support it so again whatever kind of
like migration we want to have we can do
that cool
so
thank you for your time you guys were a
fantastic audience